he just bends the rules to his own
convenience i'm some kind of horrible
evil misogynist a lot of the world's
problems could be fixed if women walked
around with their body count on their
forehead so i'd maybe go with the girl
with 50. for a rum
i don't got to introduce entertain to
you anymore i think we've seen enough of
this friggin guy but he just went on a
podcast with some of the biggest guys in
the world we'll send the full send guys
okay i don't know we've watched we i
showed you one of their videos remember
they did like the the zoom pranks back
during covid oh
shut the [ __ ] up mom i'm
that's all i saw but i really enjoyed
that that was great yeah they're funny
guys i own a couple of meta cards
they're nfts good guys so
let's get right into it metacard just
one of their nfts oh okay
so like metaverse ish yeah okay
so let's get into how many how many
girlfriends i'm a man of god i'm a good
man i don't want to be in this podcast
i'm not trying to tell the world i'm
some kind of horrible evil misogynist
everyone seems to think i am for some
reason i think it's great to have
multiple but do you yeah why not i
couldn't imagine having multiple men to
manage multiple men to manage yeah like
i can look at it from the other side and
just dealing with men and less than men
women aren't the only ones i kind of get
a headache thinking about having
multiple girlfriends too
that's that's like a pretty wild thought
you know i haven't
managed to generally have the opinion
that relationships are a pain in the ass
which i know is not a popular opinion so
to have five six seven relationships
going at once
no thanks
no i read the bible i go to church i
don't know i can't possibly answer these
questions this is obviously gonna be
watched by every single female that has
any kind of association to me and i'm
loyal to all of them
that's awesome there you go so do do do
the math on that one all of a sudden see
baby i told you i was loyal tiptoe don't
worry about it so
all of you at the same time do you think
it's possible for a man to to be loyal
to one girl
i think it's possible for men to do lots
of things sure go to the moon you little
one girl
and go scuba diving if you want to it's
pretty stupid i don't think that is it
possible if men were truly honest with
themselves that they want to be
i think men are loyal to a woman to try
and inspire loyalty out of her a man
will sit there and go i only want to be
with her but really what they're saying
is i only want her to be with me which
is a masculine imperative and it's
natural and i completely understand that
every man is the same but if you could
make a woman be loyal to you while not
being loyal to her then you would not be
loyal to her if a man's truly honest and
says if i can press this button and
she's loyal to me no matter what i do am
i still going to only be with her now
you might prefer her you might spend 99
of your time with her et cetera
completely get that but on a long enough
time frame for the rest of your human
life and she's gonna be loyal to you
regardless are you telling me that with
a without any kind of backlash from her
without the chance of her cheating
without any [ __ ] you're gonna tell
me for the next 50 years you're not
gonna [ __ ] anything ever once if she let
you why not like you know what i mean
yeah i mean i feel like everyone would
agree to that i can't say everyone would
agree to that but i'm sure there were
plenty of people that would and plenty
of women that would too if i could keep
my man totally loyal but i get to go
flirt around if i wanted to not me but
like somehow you know like some woman
not how
i just think it's different
but
well you you're not even you don't live
in this world
i don't know women are just different
they don't want to just go around
sleeping with a bunch of people that's
just weird it's totally different women
aren't meant to do that
that's just like the truth though the
truth according to andrew tate no as i
don't know i don't know i don't
understand young women today that things
are different
i think you know you know me i'm i'm
built for monogamy and i would want
somebody that was also monogamous if i
were going to trap myself in a
relationship
all right let's keep going don't go
wrong what are you rolling your eyes
about nothing a certain level of status
you can say to a woman look i love you
with all my heart i want to be with you
i'm going to take care of you but you're
not going to tell me what to do i'm in
charge because this is my life we're on
the tape train
and we're headed to
success station i'm the one driving it
and if you're gonna be on my train
certain things are gonna happen if
you're unhappy you can get off no
problem if the chick has her own train
what if she's got her own train yeah
like what like success wise yeah but but
then she can't get on stage train or
he's not going to get on her he knows
that men are naturally leaders in
relationships so he's saying these women
look to him as a leader they come into
the relationship where he's running [ __ ]
and he'll take care of them it's pretty
simple okay no
well you're certainly replaced then
you're going to accept more things than
you would except from someone who's easy
to replace right this is basic human
psychology we can take it away from
dating and apply it to basically
anything you will accept your
lamborghini breaking down because it's
hard to replace it you will not accept
your toyota breaking down because you
can just go get nissan so it's the same
kind of game right if you look at a guy
and go he is amazing at everything i
truly feel i feel happy with this man i
can't find another man on his level who
could possibly replace him or fill the
hole
in my life he would leave
sometimes he [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh fine
the thing is like with what he's talking
about it's for very high value men like
if you are the man if your guy goes and
sleeps with another girl is that what
you're gonna dump him over because the
reason most men are monogamous to their
woman is so that that woman doesn't
leave them because naturally men do want
to go around and sleep and naturally
women don't i i think you're being
really naive on what on what people do
naturally i think p there are a lot of
people who are different i said it in
the beginning some people are people men
and women are built for monogamy some
are not there are women that cheat all
the time i know so many married women
that cheat it's insane it's gross it
bothers me broken women
dude they're broken you bro
haram yeah what if what if he's the
broken one he can't be the broken one
you're tripping the reason i defend hate
is because he's has integrity he just
says this is who i am you you've got to
know who i am he doesn't say you can
take it or leave it that's his rule but
you know what the guy that's running out
and bed hopping and then coming back and
lying and saying he was doing overtime
or whatever it was he says he was doing
we're both on the same page about that
that you should be honest it's a snake
and he shouldn't be defending that kind
of behavior i'm not saying he is but he
shouldn't be advocating that we need to
get the tates on a podcast we're gonna
fly to croatia romania wherever the [ __ ]
they are and we're gonna meet them he
can come to boston
he doesn't like the us you might get
shot up here you want to do it we'll
we'll meet in italy it's fine they're
watching we were just on their youtube
video well i could accept it that's
human nature right it's not even about
intersexual dynamics and all the things
i talk about even though i could use
those examples to apply all of my
beautiful completely correct logical
you know affirmations the reason i don't
do that is because everyone comes back
because it's misogynist misogynist
misogynist so fine cool stop them all
crying let's talk about human nature
people are not going to be quick to
replace something or attempt to replace
something which is basically
irreplaceable so if you're a high enough
status individual then you get to get
away with more well that's true in
general that's true in general but there
are women like me who that's the line
like i'll put up with a lot of annoying
[ __ ] but cheating is the thing that
i'm like i just get so turned off and
that's fine everyone's allowed to have
that's what i'm saying their
requirements so i don't care how high
value of a man is if he's cheating i'm
like you know what get lost like i don't
like it's just for me that's my deal
breaker some women don't care some women
will be like they'll cry and eat their
ice cream and then just carry on because
they they want to keep the guy and they
can accept that to some extent even if
it hurts them so it's really more
individualized than he's saying i think
also generally though there are certain
things that are really natural to men
and women like prey and predator
you know i i think generally speaking
men are the reason they really go after
a woman is if she's harder to get
because they are they're 100
hunters and frankly i think i don't like
chasing men i don't know why
you know why men like to go after the
girls that are harder to get because
they've slept with less people maybe
that's i can guarantee that that 100 has
to do with it
women as a whole are quite understanding
of their status women are very very
intelligent i know what people say i'm
misogynistic and people say i say bad
things about women women are very very
intelligent in certain key areas and one
of the things they are most
intelligent
at or best at is is reading their own
status and understanding what they can
and can't get away with women are
experts at that how do you you get the
same chick who will act x-way with one
guy and get with a new guy and act
completely differently because do you
think that subconsciously though
i think it's subconscious but i also
think they spend a lot of time on
instagram a lot of time looking at their
competition a lot of time looking in the
mirror a lot of time trying to look good
a lot of time they spend a lot of time
on themselves and within themselves and
they're pretty good at understanding
their value and what they can get away
with when it's compared against the
value that's sitting opposite them right
so they'll sit opposite one guy and be a
[ __ ] and say opposite next guy and
be a sweetheart they're quite smart at
that so what's the reasoning then for
girls going to like [ __ ] guys who don't
have their [ __ ] together yeah there's
those are self-esteem issues about not
feeling good enough to have somebody
that consistently treats you well it is
that little empathy thing where they're
yeah like oh oh but he had a hard
childhood and oh you know i'm women are
more empathetic i'm going to love him
out of this he's going to try and do
that too but not as many yeah he'll
change oh he'll go back to the way he
was in the beginning
well if you're [ __ ] all these [ __ ]
how do i know i'm special so the only
reason you know you're special is
because i'm sexually exclusive so if you
knew you were special with something
else perhaps you did something else with
me or i did something else with you that
i don't do with anybody else and you
would know you were special so what
you're worried about me
finger paint together what is that what
is that something special so she says if
they're
oh if you're exclusive to me then i know
i'm special
but he's like well what if we just do
something else special so that doesn't
have to be the special thing but he's
also saying that but then on the other
hand he says women get emotionally
attached with with physical interaction
so they they really put high value on
that so he knows that about women yet
he's willing to discount it and say oh
we will go bowling together as our
special thing and i'll only go bowling
with you it doesn't make sense he's like
[ __ ] on the thing he knows is the
most important to women am i missing
something
hmm interesting point he's just make he
just bends the rules to his own
convenience i think he's just talking
about that women don't want like women
shouldn't be ah it's a weird one it is a
very weird one no he just bends the
rules to his own because if he does know
that that's what women care about i mean
i guess yeah he's he's like [ __ ] on
it but he i don't know he he's like
trying to convince them that that's not
the most special thing between us i
don't even think that he's trying to
convince them that it's not the most
special thing between us he's just
trying to convince them that he still
loves them and he can still like be with
other like sleep with other women i i
don't think that's what he said but okay
i think that's what he said but
ah females are not that logical you
can't explain it that way but i'm saying
if you're with a woman long enough and
you have frame and you have influence
over her and you understand these basic
paradigms and you you mention them in
the correct conversations at the correct
way in the correct frame over time
they'll learn to accept it i say this
and people completely have a meltdown i
don't know why people have a meltdown
it's [ __ ] stopping syndrome it's
facts do you think any of these dudes
[ __ ] you know what that is you think
any of these rappers [ __ ] all these
girls the girls are telling them you
better be loyal stockholm syndrome is
when you say you get kidnapped and after
a while you kind of fall in love with
the kidnapper and you idolize them and
you you actually do everything they say
so that you can stay with them and have
an opportunity to escape and not because
you're brainwashed that's what he's
saying over time you can convince them
yeah that's weird that's a weird thing
he's he's convincing them and
reprogramming them to do things that are
against their nature according to him
maybe
that they want loyalty and they want to
feel like sex is something special with
just that and he's like yeah you can rid
them otherwise that's the short of it
that's what i'm hearing am i missing
something i don't know i think i
wouldn't say it's like stockholm
syndrome i'd say that's pretty different
i'd say that he has his standards high
enough and he's a hot enough of a high
value man so that if he demands from a
woman that she stays loyal but he can be
with other women then that's how it
takes time over time to convince her of
that she came in now some of them are
going to be like yup i got i get to ride
in the lamborghini on tuesdays you know
the tuesday girl she's she's a tuesday
she's low value but whatever she'll take
it she's cool with whatever but there
are going to be other ones that really
do wish that they had an exclusive
relationship with a guy or with him in
the specific specifically so human human
relationships there's an a side b side
business deals there's an aside b side
someone's gotta [ __ ] take the b side
by the way or someone's gotta lose yeah
yeah to a degree it doesn't have to be a
two degree and but this is the thing
about relationships because we can talk
about relationships as a whole everyone
says what i say is crazy all i say is
that love is real
men and women should be in love a man
can be completely in love with a woman
and care about her and still sometimes
[ __ ] something else something else not
even someone else like his [ __ ]
language he's he's just the worst i like
him but he's the worst
i just see both sides that's the way i
see it i see how he looks well then then
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander so when some say you're mad
in love with a girl and you're totally
dedicated to her because you really
believe that that's the way to be and
then she just goes bounces out and like
and comes back in from the club walking
funny and you're like oh
what happened and she's like man that
was just exercise it wasn't it didn't
mean anything
my heart's with you you're going to be
cool with that no it's
it's not different it's not different
they're they're different
yes we have differences but on certain
things what's good for the goose is good
for the gander and he needs to he needs
to be okay with that his girls need to
be able to go have on other trains when
they want to
if you say so well women are also
addicted to drama this is something else
you have to understand about females
very true females are addicted to drama
young females
there's a lot of them that are i i don't
want to insult anyone i was about to say
a [ __ ] yeah i'm stick with that a [ __ ]
will sit there
a [ __ ] will sit there
and think i need to relax let me watch a
murder documentary about a serial killer
who chops people's heads off so i have a
nice good night's sleep don't look at me
like that i only watch murder
documentaries because i've already seen
all of the world war ii documentaries
okay so i i lightened up that's all you
watch at night
well because there's when they put out
new world war ii documentaries i'll
watch those i know i'm an old man what
are you going to do
why are you just going to get to this
[ __ ] they love drama
so to some degree even as a man this is
actually hit the nail on the face that's
not true [ __ ] head violence that's
violence if i really love drama i'd be
watching soap operas they're both drama
understand to some degree as a man you
have to instill drama in the
relationship because if you don't she's
going to get bored no that's very true
and she's either going to leave or she
will instill the drama which gives her
control you don't want her to bring the
drugs
girls like to fight they like drama they
like to be entertained so if she
instills the drama it's probably gonna
involve some other [ __ ] dude you
don't want that [ __ ] right so you have
to instill drama so this is the question
i always say to all the people who say
i'm misogynistic and my view on
relationships are wrong etcetera
etcetera i say look i have beautiful
women who are in love with me and we're
all happy and smiling every day i get to
[ __ ] whatever i want i have a very
positive relationship with females my
life's good
you disagree with everything i say
but your relationship you and your woman
don't even [ __ ]
so like if you take the other paradigm
99 of men disagree with me but they go
they marry one chick they be the good
guy get married sit with her just her
i'm loyal but they're all getting
[ __ ] divorced and chicks giving them
a hard time you never see that dude who
did the right thing and then go i can do
whatever the [ __ ] i want cause i do the
right thing so you know what leave her
at home and hit the club and do what i
want cause i don't cheat never it's like
ah she's gonna get mad and he's the good
guy i'm the bad guy and i get to say see
you next week so what is that what is
the cheating code
you know people grow up and stop going
to the club too
that is true but it's not just about
going to the club it's about free nobody
wants to hang out with a 45 year old guy
at the club nobody not even the 45 year
old mother looking for her daughter at
the club i see a lot of young girls at
the club but the older guys just for the
money i've seen a lot of that it's so
strange how do you
morally cheat if you have a girl you're
honest with her you're up front with her
it's not even about that because when i
say on these podcasts i have to condense
everything i have to be very compenduous
and i have to try and or how does one
not entertain how does one morally it's
just about understanding and instilling
a mental frame inside of the female that
makes her understand that it's really
not that big a deal
that coupled with your status and the
fact that you're hard to replace will
make you be able to get away with it
right get away with it i don't even mean
get away with it it can be very honest
you think that's brainwashing it's
convincing her at a minimum it is if she
is truly not built like that listen it's
fine but again she should be able to go
out and play too especially if she's got
her own train i just disagree
okay i'm
and you're truly cool and you're truly
together and she truly loves you you
come home have you been out there you
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i did [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you know what i [ __ ] her but her tits
are not as good as yours come here
she'll love it she doesn't give a [ __ ]
what if she had a better rack though
well then she's in trouble right but i'm
saying if the frame she's in trouble but
it's about the man before we continue i
just want to give a reminder that 99 of
you guys are not subscribed what really
yeah come on guys hit the button hit the
magic button right here and join the
discord i'm giving 100 to someone who
joins the discord and says hi that woman
over a long enough period of time has
the same political views likes the same
music likes the same movies has the same
friends as him watches the same things
on youtube the same netflix show women
tend to take on the personality of their
boyfriend not all women you say not all
women but for the most part broken women
you think it's just broken it's for the
most part it's like not ah dude you're
killing me right now the healthiest in
healthy relationships people do not take
on the traits and you know they have
certain things that they share and enjoy
together and then they have other things
that they go out and do each on their
own which doesn't mean other people tate
but you know it they have other
communities
if a girl
completely immerses herself in a man's
world and she stops hanging with her
friends and she stops taking that class
that she was 11 before she met him she
stops going on vacation with her friends
that's unhealthy and that's what he's
talking about but not all women do that
and you can't you can't just put all
women into that category of being
pathetic little puppies that follow men
around that's horseshit total worship
maybe in romania i don't know he's in a
different world he's like in a different
century i'm just saying that they and
what i've seen they tend to take on the
personality and the traits of the not
necessarily the traits but what they do
teenage girls well that's just that's my
experience that's what i'm saying like
what i see i've noticed that women
take on
teenage girls do those aren't women
they're just still figuring out they're
still like bambi on the ice trying to
walk
[Music]
they don't know what they're doing all
right well i'm just saying mice my
personal experience yeah with a bunch of
teenagers well someday you'll get a real
woman no time soon because that i'll
kill her mom you're a high value woman i
don't know i think that you just have a
different mindset than what really goes
on out here no i know what i was like
when i was a teenager and i was more
like pathetic and you know following you
know almost like that's how it is most
of the time and they grow out of that
women good women grow out of that and
they give a man a little bit of a
challenge and i don't mean being a [ __ ]
i just mean holding your ground and
having your own life because that's what
makes a woman more high value to a man
he doesn't ma a man doesn't want a puppy
following him around it kills his
predatory instincts kills them
emasculates him
so what if what if your girl comes home
same scenario and goes uh yo your dick
is bigger that's not gonna make you
happy though
bro okay so this this argument is one
i've heard so many trillion times they
say well if you can do that
why can't the woman do that let's see
and i can answer it in so many different
ways
my harshest way is that it goes against
the will of god in nature it goes
against the way of man for the longest
period of human history men had more
than one woman every king every sultan
read the bible read the quran and most
of the world today men still have more
than one woman never in history in any
book ever in any civilization since the
dawn of human time have promiscuous
women been celebrated ever they have
been frowned upon in every single
society so i look at that i look at that
in two ways because he talks about the
history thing and i'm like well you
can't just say for the longest time
because there's been things like his
like uh slavery that have happened so
you can't just be like well forever
there were slaves so it's okay that i
think that's a weird way to look at it i
don't know the bible well i don't know
how well he actually knows the bible he
says he studies it but i do know what i
what i do know of the bible is a lot of
time the kings that were in the bible
you know all their things were listed
that they were doing and they were being
condemned by god so i don't think i i've
never heard and i want to know now does
the bible say oh yes god wishes many men
you know that you have many wives i
where is that the quran is a different
thing it's a different religion it's a
whole bunch of stuff that i have trouble
with all right let's keep going what am
i talking about because what happens is
we got 12 minutes in we got a little
ways to go we're pregnant we know who
the five mothers guys are in town thank
you and we know who the five fathers are
well the father the father for the fact
i heard that right no she said if a
woman's pregnant and she only slept with
one man we know who the father is but if
she slept with five men you don't know
who the father is right that's like
since before like 50 years ago when dna
[ __ ] came out that's how you knew
that your woman was loyal to you so that
you're raising that kid and you know
it's yours not necessarily but oh my god
you're so naive you have to
look in like you need to watch more
documentaries is what you need to do and
read more because truly there are or
listen to the old people there are so
many stories in every single family of
scandal and and cheating and second fit
men who had second families i'm talking
about families that we know like we'll
talk about it off camera sorry but there
was so much scandal let's just talk
about 20th century alone people we know
in our first or second circles okay and
so a woman slept with three guys back
then and she got pregnant she picked the
highest value man to marry say this is
your baby i'm pregnant i love you
because she wasn't gonna go with it you
know joe schmoe from the bar who she had
sex with in the bathroom and you know
might have been his kid but the high
value man who's going to provide the
most for her and her child to make her
life easier because women were more
practical they wanted to be in love but
they were okay with that's practical
what's your what's your point though
because i mean that's that's that's
gross to hear but my point because he's
saying if the woman came to you then you
know that's your child no you don't that
she's loyal if she's loyal then you know
it's your child that was the point not
your wife's a whole going around
cheating if she said no [ __ ] that kid
might not be yours you know
you're looking over i thought i heard
something you know what you gotta
lighten up on me pal no who the kids
belong to yeah if you have a woman who's
sleeping with five dudes when she gets
pregnant nobody knows who the [ __ ]
belongs to now the dna test might be
able to fix that modern science right
but there's a whole bunch of modern
science has to work the devil that
shit's new humans
evolutionarily grew up until the 1950s
1960s where none of that [ __ ] was doable
you had to know who the mother and the
father was you had to have a virgin
that's what that's why they celebrate
virginia in most these places on the
planet they can't do a four dna test if
she a virgin i don't know as a fact i'm
the i'm the father so i gotta [ __ ]
deal with her [ __ ] that's why virginia
is so important in most of the world to
this day uh after a marriage after the
wedding night they would have to hang
the sheet outside of the house and if
there was a little bit of blood on it
that meant that the woman was a virgin
because he broke her hymen which is like
a yeah right but sometimes that can
break um in exercise horseback riding
things like that so if that didn't
happen for a woman
she would have to like cut herself and
put some blood on the sheet
so that she didn't get you know outcast
golf which is a little extreme you can
come along with science well then trying
to definitely see it
so
god just wants the boys to just run
through chase god wants the warriors
like god's looking down right now and
he's like boys i just want you to run
through chicks god is that god warns us
god speaks men the masculine males of
earth to reproduce this
man is so full of himself that he's
speaking for god
like he's speaking as if he's got the
the hotline to the lord come on tate
pull yourself together yes surprisingly
ladylike but what about what about have
you ever dated a girl that makes more
money than you that's impossible it's
possible what do you mean what if what
if you what if like what if you when you
finally go to the us you're in l.a and
kylie jenner pulls up on you what if
like and she's like she's still not
returning what if she's dating you oprah
is richer than you
and oprah should be a couple [ __ ] no
ten thousand oh i can't see but thanks
tweet ten thousand subscribers thank you
everybody that's so lit
100k next bam all right let's keep going
i made that
would you ever date a girl it's richer
than you [ __ ] yes
yeah why not so then would you let her
pay bills i spent most of my life dating
dating girls who were rich with me like
for a long time i had no money
and i dated [ __ ] she might have more
money that was no problem for me because
i was still in control i'm still in
charge
mastering frame is not all about money
the idea that it's all money is not true
at all right i did very very well in my
life when i had no money and i was i was
a professional fighter and i was on the
way up and i was fighting i didn't
really have that much money i did fine
so what if you're well there are there
are dudes in new york right now selling
cds on the street with like four
girlfriends and they're just tearing
through [ __ ] everyone knows this
on the slide they're doing fine so are
they just about but then what leverage
do you have over them if you're not
taking care of them like what if kylie
jenner's like what you're on my jet it's
bigger than yours like you can't [ __ ]
cheat on girls now if i'm if i'm if i'm
just dip at that point if i'm on that
job
it depends on the girl and her mindset
she may just still be looking for
true love because she's got everything
else in the world and there's still a
hole that's not filled so she may still
get into a toxic relationship with
somebody who is gonna you know jump on
anything that passes by or or any other
toxic trait in a relationship be mean to
her or whatever what if it says kylie's
skin on the outside
because if she's my chick do you make
her pull off a decal no no i should keep
it but if she's my chick then you know
she's mine so her things are now mine's
my jet my house
this is my jet young lady sit down
be quiet it's gonna be fine don't worry
about it i thought we had a montana
whoever it's gonna be okay [ __ ] i'd
[ __ ] open the door mid-flight and
push this [ __ ] out like if he said
something like that to me i don't give a
[ __ ] you're on my jet talking to me like
that open the door push you out no
parachute
don't do that to me tate none of my chat
i said it would if girls would have
their body count or whatever keep going
entertaining everything way easier
how so how would it be displayed i don't
know exactly what you said after that
but i know i'm here on this podcast you
guys you don't even understand what i
said i'm i'm i'm upset because we want
we want the audience to know so we need
you to dive into it i said that a lot of
the world's problems could be fixed
if women walked around with their body
parts on their forehead i've heard him
said this say this before but i've never
heard him say
which problems could be fixed a lot of
the world's problems could be fixed if
women walked around with their body
count on their forehead what problems
could be fixed knowing if she slept with
a bunch of people because that is more
likely to lead to a destructive
relationship all right but that's not
one of the world's biggest problems like
obviously just an exaggeration you got
to take everything he says with a grain
of salt with how he says it okay i i
yeah are you you should know that but i
do know not to be too literal but you
know he doesn't really even say what
problems at all even on a smaller scale
so you know it's annoying
hunger let's see maybe he'll get into it
society
at large could benefit from that
scenario
what does that fix because you have to
extrapolate it you have to extrapolate
it and look at it at the point if women
can't just sleep with anybody and
everybody because they're going to be
known for it and shamed for it they're
going to be very very selective with who
they sleep with if they're very very
selective then men are going to have to
be very very they're going to be very
very hard working and very very
dedicated to becoming a man worth
sleeping with so now men are going to be
more honorable men are going to try
harder men are going to be more
interested in making sure that they're
that would be a very standing dynamic
women are going to be very selective who
they choose they're more likely to stick
with a guy through thick and thinks they
don't add a new number to their head
families will return
the families are at extension families
are an extension of society as a whole
right it's family then it's town then
it's city that's pretty state
so he wants it both ways though he wants
guys to be able to you know jump on
anything that they can and he wants
women to stay more modest how did the
numbers add up would you just get like a
group of women who were just i was
thinking that dancing so he's saying
yeah no no i i totally get what you're
saying that that made me that was making
me think too because of like if men can
just sleep around but women have to stay
monogamous like where are these where
are these women coming from that you're
sleeping with but he's saying right
there that if men if women weren't as
powish and that they were you know they
only slept with like a few people then
men would have to increase their status
a ton to be able to get those girls and
get those higher women that's what he's
saying right there well i think it was i
think we could just go back in time just
a few decades and see that in reality
where men really worked to build a home
and be the man of the house
and make sure they could provide for a
family and women were really preserving
themselves and waiting for that right
guy and maybe maybe in the 50s they had
in their 40s you know they had a couple
little indiscreet things that happened
but in but but excuse me disgrace very
discreet things that happened because
and it did and that did exist where men
worked harder for a woman and they
respected women more in some in in some
ways in that way of like becoming a
family man so he's not wrong but he's
forgetting that it's already happened
and we've moved away from it so body
count i don't think would solve it but i
think that a change in values would they
should make a black mirror episode about
that yeah sure they should try it
because i disagree of course you
disagree but i'll tell you why of course
because it's different like if you're
looking for a one-night stand and one
chick has three bodies and one chick has
50 the chick with 50 is going to give
you a way freakier night than the chick
with three so i'd maybe go with the girl
with 50. you're gonna walk around
looking for chicks thinking i want one
that smells like one night
i want one who's been plowed
who's going to give you a free yeah yeah
i wouldn't want that i don't think
anything bro one night
okay
he has high he has high value options he
just wants a girl to freaking but you
know a 16 year old teenage boy who finds
out that you know maria down the street
gives everyone uh you know a good time a
good time thank you okay i was looking
for the words a good time he's going to
be like
hi maria like
i want to go first can i go
too want to go for a soda yeah i mean
you know
of course he he has the luxury of
picking and choosing yeah but that's i
just think that's because men naturally
do they just want to freaking they just
want to get a girl you don't see 16 year
old women go 16 year old girls going to
the guy that sleeps well most guys sleep
with everyone but you don't see them
going down and being like oh oh can can
i go get a soda with you you have a part
of that strictly hormonal teenagers
aren't run by their brains they're run
by their hormones it goes back to the
nature of it men just want to sleep
around and they don't get emotionally
attached men and boys are two different
things you can't compare a 16 year old
boy to a 35 year old man you can't if i
sit there with some [ __ ] she's like
i've been there i've been that i went to
this party my friend has a jet i was in
this lambo
and you're just like shut the [ __ ] up
there's nothing less attractive because
we want to be their portal to the world
the reason women don't understand this
is they sometimes think especially if
they're sitting with a g like they sit
with a guy like me they feel like they
have to prove themselves
by pretending they've been with other
ballers right they don't want to sit
there with a man like me and go oh i've
never been into a restaurant like this i
wish they would say that that's the most
[ __ ] attractive thing they could say
to me but instead they'll say yeah i've
been here that uh my friend uh and i did
this
they dropped dubai and then it's over
well that's like the name
the name dropping thing and it it
doesn't matter what way it's going if
it's in business if it's in romantic on
a date like somebody that's
name-dropping it's just unattractive so
a girl coming in when someone's trying
to impress you when you can feel the
trying part that's what's gross i think
if a woman came in and said oh yeah i
was here before it was awesome like i
had a great time i'm so psyched to be
back that would cover it you know he
that wouldn't give him that unattractive
feeling because she was nonchalant and
she was also appreciative but when you
can feel the trying and a woman can feel
it from a man and a man can feel it from
a woman you know what i'm saying just
does that make a difference in your man
in your man mind i kind of get what
you're saying i don't know what you mean
by the name dropping thing it's similar
to name dropping saying oh i've ridden
in a lamborghini and i've uh you know
i've i've been to this place so many
times with my friends oh the last time i
was here uh because when girls were
going all these nice places at the next
table it was so awesome like you know it
seems like it was so much cooler than
when we were here but yeah but i'm
really just trying to impress you like
people do that especially when they get
around famous people because they get
they get self-conscious they either they
get nervous or they're just trying so
hard to impress them and make them feel
like they're at their level meanwhile if
you can tell someone's trying really
hard to impress you it is pretty cringy
because it diminishes that factor of
wanting a chase and one and a half to
earn it yeah i don't know like this all
goes back there's a reason why guys
don't naturally want a woman that's
slept with a bunch of guys it's because
it doesn't mean anything she's already
been with a bunch of other dudes like
you sleeping with her there was no
conquest there was no having to earn it
it's like
nothing it's like going hunting and
shooting a deer that was already laying
there mostly dead like you did really
wow you go to the [ __ ] you go to the
zoo and shoot a deer big [ __ ] deal
you know that's what it is right you
know i want to be the person who shows
her something for the first time i don't
want to [ __ ] a [ __ ] she's been [ __ ]
every way she could be [ __ ]
like why is it that something new now
backflips
maybe he's doing backflip i don't know
but to me that's all people are missing
the point that is true that is true i
think uh
girls do think it is symmetrical that
way oh man girls girls like the same
thing girls and you know you know what's
worse about chicks on dates
this is not young girl [ __ ] though
this isn't this doesn't grow and i don't
know listen
he doesn't want grown woman though he
wants young women that haven't slept
with a lot of people i'm just saying i
know that that's that's just what he
wants that are obey obedient and
submissive that's just his preference
i'm just saying that doesn't sound that
bad for the people out there
there's a grown woman [ __ ] this is this
is girl [ __ ] and it just people need to
understand that this this woman talk
doesn't apply as women grow and don't
you interrupt this is important this is
as women grow and age and experience
things they change so you're talking
about teenagers and women in their 20s
and some of them stay on that trajectory
until the day they die and they're just
begging for attention this [ __ ] doesn't
apply to 99 of people because 99 of
people are working average ass jobs not
really doing that much
with business that's not what i'm saying
but this is like such a unique scenario
that what he's talking about that it
doesn't even up like it doesn't even
involve majority of bombs that are
sitting there watching this [ __ ] you
know what i mean well i do but this
stuff can is actually applicable to
everyone just regardless of their
different levels economic status it's
different levels
listen there could be a guy living in
the shittiest neighborhood in america
and it just
every every girl in the trailer park is
like let's go and there's the one pretty
girl down the end who's got self-respect
and is a little more modest and that's
the one that he's really thinking god
that's wife material busy [ __ ] social
[ __ ] unattractive next thing that's
unattractive that women do is when they
[ __ ] say you think all social [ __ ]
are [ __ ] though
what if they're out there just grinding
it's about that men don't want that i'm
talking about pure just attraction she
could be an innocent angel doing all
these things the fact that still she's
going to sit there with me and start
talking about all these places she goes
i don't want to hear that i want to hear
innocence purity sit at home don't i
don't like when they're [ __ ] but i kind
of find it hot when they have their own
[ __ ] going you ever own [ __ ] going from
home
but what are you going to talk about
with a woman that just sits at home and
plays with her nails all day i mean what
is this guy talking about i this what's
his fella's name kyle kyle yeah i could
see kyle's point more that it's more
interesting to to be with somebody
that's interesting i would definitely
agree with more with kyle here i like a
girl who's more hard-working and driven
but then i also like it when she doesn't
go to clubs and go to frat parties
because i don't like that [ __ ] but you
don't want her sitting inside reading
the bible all day that's also a little
bit much yeah it's it's too extreme but
again tate wants women who have nothing
going on because a woman that's really
got a full interesting life isn't going
to join his harem that's not haram harem
how wrong it's like a girl ever brought
you back to meet her parents and if she
does do you do you act this way like you
be real parents love me i feel like
parents would love tate because he takes
care of the girls and he's a very
respectful person you know what i mean
yeah no i'm sure he i have no doubt that
he can carry himself with with a dad but
he's very intelligent he knows what to
say to the right people yeah he knows
what he's doing i'm sure he can be
totally smooth i'm sure and i can
already see it but i mean if the dad
knew that there were six other women at
home that you know his daughter was just
wanting a posse
yeah
that's gonna change any decent dad's
opinion just depends on the values maybe
in eastern europe that's more normal
than compared to growing up in the
united states i've never heard of it but
yeah
isn't it like in most like muslim
countries and stuff don't the guys have
multiple wives isn't that normal in like
the middle east yeah like yeah that's
what i understand extremists
i mean like yeah osama bin laden had a
bunch of wives but they also treat women
like worse than yeah they can't drive
they're just in like paper bags like
they just don't care yeah yeah it's
pretty it's pretty wild i'm telling this
for all the chicks who watch the podcast
let's say you're on a date with a guy
and you really want to get him
you ain't been nowhere you ain't done
[ __ ] you're an undiscovered diamond
i don't know i've never been to a place
like that oh how do i open the car door
i don't know how lambo car doors work oh
i've never done this i've never been
there i've never been on holiday
that's what a man wants to hear he does
that's what i do when i go on a date i
act like you don't even exist what are
you just kidding i don't have a kid oh i
don't know yeah i've never been married
i don't have any children oh yeah yeah
haram wrong
all right i think that's a good place to
cut off here we're gonna keep recording
the rest of the reaction to this whole
video let me know if you guys want part
two and as a reminder i'm giving away a
hundred dollars to someone who likes
subscribes and then joins the discord in
my bio you got any final remarks for
this part no i just can't wait to see
the rest of this nonsense hope you guys
want to see the rest drop a comment
[Music]